hello there reject nation greg and john
here today we are going to watch
from new rock stars the loki end credits
breakdown
easter eggs clues and all that we
watched their breakdown video in easter
eggs for episode one the other day and
at the end of it he did say
there was just so much in here that it
had to be a separate video
i say you're just milking it and good on
you guys there's a lot to mine from here
ride that algorithm go for it eric
actually says something very nice to us
on twitter
uh yesterday did you see it i haven't
seen it yet
because i'm the one who has to keep up
to date with all this hey yeah
winning over the real rejects is my
glorious
purpose little brings me more
gratification than when you two shout
enjoy it's something i bring up nothing
brings me more abject terror
than when you pause after one of my rush
half lift theories to question it
let's dance boys oh i'm
i'm so i'm very complete right now in
this moment
yes we have these awesome tva jackets
yeah and um yeah and um we shot an
unboxing video for it i think this video
is going up first
we're messing with time oh the sacred
timeline of
when you unboxed these
[Music]
and um welcome back to new rockstars i'm
eric voss and loki episode 1 has arrived
bringing with it a freaking glossary of
new marvel terms and insane easter eggs
but just as many if not more details are
hidden in the
end credit sequence of every episode and
looking closely at these might clue us
in even more about what this series is
really all about so i'm gonna comb
through these end credits framed by
braintree hey
we begin with loki's case file his thumb
prints that the tba used to match loki
to his crimes but underneath it is a
report referring to loki's plea
agreement it looks like it's been hard
to make out but it seems to reference
him pleading guilty to count
two but not to all of it maybe since
loki admitted guilt to being the god of
mischief and finding this all tedious
but not to violating the sacred timeline
yeah it's a bit weird for
names to be redacted though since the
tba seems like a secret organization
even loki didn't know about
so what public scrutiny would they have
to worry about
unless some higher reps of the tv are
keeping secrets from their own ranks
it's a total conspiracy
[Music]
whoever wrote that little redaction
statement and all that and everything
about his plea
must be so happy this video because
man someone put a lot of thought into
writing that up
and someone's waiting for a little
acknowledgement yeah
i wasn't waiting to get noticed for that
somebody's job that's graphic design
that is a cool little detail and i i
love the editing here on this new
rockstars vid so far directed by kate
herron appears over a coffee pot labeled
fresh
800 bc maybe a nod to herron's coffee
drinking but also a joke about how the
tba apparently drinks discontinued
beverages from the past
like justa and boku coffee wasn't
reportedly drank until like the 15th
century but who knows maybe it was
way older and just forgotten from
history then we see another tvh poster
hunters and analysts working in tandem
a tall female minutemen pulled out high
five to a wormy little analyst
who is low fiving sacred timeline
dividing them
yeah they look like they're cool they do
not connect
reflecting how the tva desk workers like
casey don't really get along with hunter
b15
and that bureaucratic weakness could get
exploited by loki and by others
i like that i mean that theory that he's
bringing up about that bureaucratic
weakness because
casey you know he did get some shining
moments in the first episode of loki
yeah that is a neat
that is such a good damn it boss that is
such a good detail to pick up on
because you do see that between the
minutemen and the desk workers it seems
like there's not much
of a like any kind of respect between
the two of them it looks like they look
down on them but there's more worker
bees and there are minutemen so if loki
wants to somehow hijack tva in some
fashion ah dude yeah you got my mind
going
you got my mind going vos the right of
that are some pinned
equations and figures you actually get
clearer shots of this later in the
sequence
figure r shows these variants a stick
figure with nine
duplicates branching off from him
remember that number nine but then
drawings of wormholes aka einstein rows
and bridges
and then beneath that hold onto your
butts schrodinger's equation
so erwin schrodinger was a theoretical
physicist known for pioneering quantum
mechanics
and the many worlds theory disputing
einstein's explanation of newtonian
physics he really was all about trying
to quantify what he called the waveform
of subatomic particles
ultimately positing that bodies can
exist simultaneously in multiple
parallel realities
you might know his thought experiment
schrodinger's cat in which he is
all i know his cat in a closed box with
two dishes of food one of them poisoned
while that lid stays closed and he can't
observe the cat that
cat is both simultaneously alive and
dead in two parallel reality states now
marvel studios is clearly well-versed in
these concepts
eric selvig's chalkboard and thor the
dark world reference jody nurse cat
ant-man
the movie that mocked quantum everything
and set up kang the conqueror's home
city of chronopolis and the quantum
realm
also discussed this idea from bill
foster the object in question would be
both in
and out of phase with multiple parallel
realities
and an avengers end game built on this
consulting experts in quantum mechanics
to produce
its explanation of branch realities
which is how we got dialogue like
tony after everything you've seen is
anything really quantum fluctuation
messes with the planck scale which then
triggers the deutsche proposition can we
agree on that
and now loki is building on endgame's
timeline logic with loki's escape from
the time heists creating a
branch timeline that captain america
never restored making loki a variant on
the tva's [ __ ] list
and by the way after episode 1 if that
background variant was peggy carter
maybe even cap's decision to stay in the
past with peggy created another nexus
violation a branch timeline
that the tba plans
sequence nearby those equations is a
figure showing overlapping and
concentric circles
around nine of them at least including
that donut at the top and another circle
inside it with a line pointing directly
to the center
labeled tva possibly showing us the
location of the tva
in between the nine realms and then just
oh not bad
god these are the most detailed wow
these are i know right i'm like i feel
like i'm in class right now you want to
really understand the world of the tv
just just pay attention not to the
people who worked in the subject
oh man holy crap those clues were
sprinkled in from the very beginning
like us as long as the mcu exists we're
going to keep
asking ourselves how far in advance do
they think of certain things yeah
yeah like cutting back to all these
footage remember like phase two movies
and stuff
like damn linking to schrodinger's
quantum physics
theories and such that's mind-boggling
but if it is connected to the nine
realms as well
that is the a version of tying in like
the science and fantasy even that much
more considerate the
tva has tussled with thor and loki in
the comics and such
joe you know what i'm trying to say
there's tie-ins and then to the far left
a tva archive
apocalyptic event report under event
details
failure to intervene in dire
circumstances and then beneath that
fri capital f maybe friday or the person
that day of the week is based on
the norse figure of friega so this could
be a report about loki's failure to
intervene
in the dark elves attack on asgard later
in the sequence another apocalyptic
event report describes loki's hijacking
of the seattle flight as db cooper in
1971 which we saw in the episode
so the tva considers each of these
apocalyptic events
which maybe could connect these kind of
reports to loki's upcoming interference
with the destruction of pompeii which
was truly apocalyptic to those people
exec producer stephen broussard shows up
over a thick
reference book underneath that book is
another apocalyptic event report
based on the formatting of it and then
notice there's a tab in this reference
book that opens up to
atlas so maybe someone is researching
past apocalyptic events
in world history like pompeii exec
producer kate herron over some light up
switches on a chrono monitor board
each button labeled with these three
character codes which maybe correspond
to the buttons on the tva
elevator especially since the orange one
at the bottom of that board
appears to show miss minutes as we have
an elevator button for miss minutes
go exec producer kevin r wright over
this diagram of this
variant branching down into five variant
figures
his circle head toggling into a square
triangle pentagon hexagon and x
we actually see these guys again later
this is probably some textbook or some
handbook explaining the whole variance
number of these guys does parallel the
yellow bow tied man in miss minutes
cartoon
who also spawn the same number of
variants so another page shows a figure
running through a portal with the words
effects on the left and then you can
make out the words a strip of paper
giving it
then the ends back together then draw a
line along the center
and then runs along both yeah maybe this
is explaining how the tda portals
through time
with the strip of paper bending and its
ends time back together essentially
describing a mobius strip
which tony stark used to decode time
travel back in home game
you see line producer trish standard
over a bluey gum
that mobius strip man they i'm not
pausing to contribute anything i just
need to
you need to prepare my brain my head
hurts
it's gonna be scanners in here in a
minute you just slow down eminem you're
rapping too fast
slow it down we need to be able to
understand you
i need a second to take in this whole
mobius strip
there are so many obviously some things
or things he's theorizing on and there's
other parts you're like no that's
definitely in there
to further enhance the world building of
specifically the time variance authority
within the mcu
never thought you could get so much
credits as you say
well now they're in a position probably
to just go through the entire mcu
catalog
and just mine that especially in this
show for any little
piece of information they can throw in
okay here we go you see line producer
trish standard over kablooey gum
flavor blueberry this is all in a tva
evidence bag so yeah that temporal aura
analysis mobia ordered
will probably end up yielding something
then edited by paul zucker over the tva
holo projector 35 which by the way is
actually a welteron
2004's baseball eight-track stereo from
1971. and we get a closer
because that's how editors used to have
to manually clip and paste film strips
in the days of linear editing my
breakdown has an interesting easter egg
of something written on this film strip
now the upms and assistant directors
show over the elevator buttons and
notice that the screen jumps from tsy
fhf 2we iul and right when it hits
one e j access denied so some part of
the tva must be off limits and maybe
this floor is for that
nightmare one all right maybe uh tie
into the character nightmare from the
doctor strange world a lot of nightmares
just
has his own department within the tv
he's just at a desk he's annoyed he's
like jay jones and jamie
snipers aren't scary enough what are you
doing come on what what
forget about your kids one eric boss is
not the first person to point that out
that's a common thing about how
it's a nightmare maybe it links to
nightmare in some way i would like there
to be a video just dedicated to that
people who are way smarter than us if it
is a department for nightmare like
what does that mean what would that tail
what to do like what it's just a nod to
nightmare or you know what i mean is it
further april is it confirmation of
astral projection
by you know the the rest of people in
the world in the mcu who aren't like
mystically inclined maybe visual effects
producer allison paul over more tva
paperwork where a mind stone
is actually being used as a paperweight
as casey said many of them do
then eugene cordero's name appears over
one of the tva clocks with suddenly many
alternate colored hands
note that the green one is longest
patiently ticks its way backwards
maybe like our loki variant patiently
divides the natural flow of time
tara strong's name appears over a binder
for if you look at that label
redacted reports again not sure why
anything would need to get redacted in
an organization facing zero public
scrutiny unless total conspiracy
and then this archive drawer with number
nine circled
now well earlier there's this geometric
shape with numbered corners but the
corner with nine
is circled there there could be a
connection here with the nine realms
maybe nine is the maximum number of
variants one can have that will just be
the magic number we look for in looking
now on mobius's desk
is wake magazine looks like a jet ski in
water sports magazine
and if you look like poster free poster
inside
and then we end on the faces of the
timekeepers that we saw in the courtroom
and we specifically punch in on the
middle one now compared to the other two
faces
mustachy being the timekeeper xanthe and
stalk eyebrows being bored
that leaves this middle one as asked but
here maybe it's a perspective thing but
doesn't ask's right eye look like it's
drooping down
like right before we cut to black now i
know i've compared ask's appearance here
in the courtroom to the face of jonathan
majors playing kang the conqueror in
quantum mania
a character romantically linked with
justice rent slayer framed right in this
figure's lips
let him just say yeah by closing the
credits on this stroke suffering
timekeeper clearly the show wants
us to keep a less droopy eye on them
that is true
that is true new loki inspired merch
options this is great
great video i ordered one yesterday
um follow me on instagram and twitter at
ea boss follow me rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for a great downs up
everything loki thanks for watching bye
cut at the end of the video okay that
was amazing
yeah dude that was amazing my gosh so
much in there i feel like there's going
to be a third episode
still just based on things about this
pilot oh my god the gift that keeps on
giving
loki trade i have a feeling by episode
four my brain will be fried we try to
keep up with the amount of
deep diving there is to digest this
world guys
subscribe to new rockstars if you
haven't done so already because they
just hit
3 million subscribers so do yourself a
favor
and follow the rockstar train hit that
like button
click that notification bell last but
not least
you said jt road gate jt
you got 45 seconds john jt from hawaii
i just wanted to shout you out your name
popped out at me
on the list and i was like i miss jt and
i wonder where in the galaxy he is right
now probably in hawaii because that's
where you live but man
i hope you're doing well summer's coming
on you gonna get out to the beach
send me a beach pick that's what i want
43 seconds
i want to see you i'm going to send you
this jacket and i want to see you in
nothing
but the jacket remember idea that's my
idea
for this day 41 seconds so uh i hope
you're doing well
and uh yeah i'm gonna send you some
sunscreen to
40 seconds wow nine seconds left god um
okay
jt listen time works differently during
these shout outs jt so we're gonna be
here a while so look
41 what i need you to do is i need you
to get me a few infinity stones mostly
time stones that's that's what i
kind of need the most help with okay
anyway jt i love you
and uh you know just keep your pledge
and uh you're one of the oldest patrons
we have
you